>> YOUR DAD AND I WILL BE BACK
ON SUNDAY.
REMEMBER, NO PARTIES.
>> WE PROMISE!
[ HONKING ]
>> DAMN IT, RONALD.
I'M COMING.
>> IT'S ON!
♪ WHIP OUT THE PHONE
STARTS SENDING TEXTS
OUR PARENTS ARE GONE
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS NEXT ♪
♪ HAVING A PARTY
SHOULD BE COOL
[ DOORBELL ]
WHO'S HERE
THE ENTIRE SCHOOL ♪
♪♪♪
♪ EVERYBODY CAME
THE JOCKS AND THE GEEKS
POPULAR GIRLS THE GOTHS
AND THE FREAKS ♪
♪ CLASS CLOWN CRUSHING BEER
HE IS LOSING
NERDS PLAYING BEER PONG
HE IS LOSING ♪
♪ THE QUARTERBACK'S HERE
THAT'S HELLA LIT
GLAD YOU CAME THROUGH
PARTY'S LEGIT ♪
♪ STONER KIDS ROLLING UP
A SICK ASS BLUNT
SITTING ON THE COUCH IS
MY AP ENGLISH TEACHER ♪
♪ CAUSE WE'RE HAVING A PARTY
HELLA FUN
PARTY
WHY'D YOUR TEACHER COME ♪
♪ PARTY
IT'S KIND OF WEIRD RIGHT
PARTY AT MY HOUSE TONIGHT ♪
♪♪♪
♪ PARTY POPPING UP
THAT'S HOW IT GOES THOUGH
MR. B'S LOOKING AT MY
FAMILY PHOTOS ♪
♪ NURSING A BEER
AS HE TOURS MY HOME
HEY ZACK WAS THIS
TAKEN IN ROME ♪
♪ YO SIS MR. B CAME
I KNOW HE DID
WHY IS HE HERE
HE'S GOT A WIFE AND A KID ♪
♪ IS HE CREEPING ON GIRLS
NO HE'S BEING POLITE
THEN WHY THE [ BLEEP ]
IS HE HERE ♪
♪ JUST CHILL ALL RIGHT
HE AIN'T DOING NO HARM
DON'T PAY HIM ATTENTION ♪
♪ IT'S JUST WEIRD
THAT HE'S HERE
WATCHING SHAWSHANK
REDEMPTION ♪
♪♪♪
>> ANDY DUFRESNE.
♪ MIDNIGHT COMES AND
THE PARTY'S STILL PACKED
CUTE SOPHOMORE SAYS
THERE YOU ARE ZACK ♪
♪ WANT TO CHILL IN YOUR ROOM
PARTY'S KIND OF LOUD
MR. B.'S WITH THE VAPE RATS
YEAH GREAT CLOUD ♪
♪ SHOW ME YOUR ROOM
YO HE'S DRINKING A BUNCH
THE CLOUD SMELLS AMAZING
IS THAT CAPTAIN CRUNCH ♪
♪ MR. B.'S HAVING THE
TIME OF HIS LIFE
'TIL HE GETS A CALL
MUST BE HIS WIFE ♪
♪ HE FORCED THE CALL
STARES OFF INTO SPACE
TWIRLS HIS WEDDING RING
BLANK LOOK ON HIS FACE ♪
♪ HE'S GOING THROUGH
SOME STUFF
MID LIFE CRISIS ♪
♪ NO DEEPER THAN THAT
IT'S NONE OF OUR BUSINESS
♪ CAUSE WE'RE HAVING A PARTY
GIVING INTO ME
PARTY
MOVIE MAN OBSESSED ♪
♪ PARTY
WHO INVITED
♪ PARTY AT MY HOUSE TONIGHT ♪
♪ 3:00 A.M.
NIGHT'S COMING TO AN END
TIME TO SAY GOOD-BYE
TO ALL OUR FRIENDS ♪
♪ PARTY WAS EPIC
PARTY'S THE BEST
MAYBE CHECK ON MR. B THOUGH
HE HASN'T LEFT ♪
♪ HEADING HOME MR. B
HEY THERE ZACK
GOD I MISS HIGH SCHOOL
WISH I COULD GO BACK ♪
♪ HA HA THAT'S COOL
CAN WE CALL YOU A LYFT
IT GOES BY FAST
CHERISH IT ♪
♪ WELL YOU SHOULD
PROBABLY ROLL
IF YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN ♪
♪ I'D KILL MY OWN MOTHER
FOR A TIME MACHINE
OKAY WELL
PROMISE ME GUYS ♪
♪ YOU'LL JUST BE ALIVE
WHILE YOU'RE YOUNG AND ALIVE ♪
>> RIGHT.
>> SLEEP WITH EVERYONE.
YOU'RE ONLY YOUNG ONCE.
MAKE IT FUN.
>> YOU'RE HAVING ONE MORE?
>> YEAH.
GREAT PARTY.
>> HOLD UP, MR. B, ARE YOU GOOD
TO DRIVE?
>> NOT EVEN CLOSE, BUT I GOT A
RIDE.
>> IT IS 3:00 IN THE MORNING,
RICHARD.
>> I'M SORRY.
>> WHAT IS GOING ON WITH YOU
LATELY?
>> I DON'T KNOW, OKAY?
♪ PARTY AT MY HOUSE TONIGHT